and the game award goes to nolan north
people are trying to interpret your
speech oh yeah
care to can't clear there's no
clarification it's you know ten years of
my life it's a big stage to be able to
thank those people that that just don't
get a lot of the credit overall because
they're behind the scenes their
performance matters more than mine I
really was amazed at how people just ran
with it in so many different directions
it was meant to be a sincere thank you
don't drag everybody that's me
you might recognize the voice aw crap
there we go Sully get down in between
takes and just you know keeping the
light with my castmates and friends I
created this character Jerry Lansing but
it was just this pompous self-important
narcissistic character who you know
considered himself the king of mocap
stop breathin stop breathin the joke's
on you Alan Tudyk was originally going
to be in uncharted 4 and he saw me doing
this character and he sent me the script
for comment he said there's a character
in this script and just read it as your
character Jerry and tell me what you
think and the rest is history it was
kismet you know it was and I thank him
for that you know he was the first
person ever in the on-camera world to
trust me with with funny ah no ad-libs
he just ad-libbed there since let's talk
about turning uncharted into a movie
yeah what do you think of that well you
know I think if they take a page from
the Assassin's Creed book where they've
they based a a new script around those
characters they're gonna hit a home run
joe carnahan is writing the script I had
dinner with him and he seems like he's
gonna he knows the franchise really well
and I bet he's going to deliver
something solid and you know John levy I
guess is directing and
you know how great with stranger things
you know so I I think I think it's in
good hands
[Music]
you